Ich bin nicht der offizielle Kirchenjesus, der unter Polizisten, Vandies, Richtern, Hänkern, Offizieren, Kirchenbossen, Politikern und ähnlichen Vertretern der Macht geduldet wird.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 34. Es gab eine längere Pause hier bei Chaosradio Express. Daran war auch unter anderem die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft schuld auf ihrer Art und deswegen fangen wir auch damit gleich an. Es geht heute um die WM-Tickets. Mein Name wie immer, Tim Pritlove, zu Gast ist Henryk und gleich geht's los. So, hallo, da sind wir wieder. Ich sag erstmal hallo, Henryk.
Hallo Tim.
Das Mikrofon funktioniert wunderbar. Ja, die WM, na das war ja eine Sache. Ich glaub Fußball ist gar nicht so dein Kernthema, trotzdem hast du dich ja recht ausgiebig mit dieser WM beschäftigt, oder?
Zumindest mit den Tickets, einem Teil davon.
Zumindest mit den Tickets, genau. Um die ganze Eingangssituation von der WM und den ganzen Hin und Her, wie das mit den Tickets lief, da gab es ja eine ganze Menge Presse und auch eine ganze Menge Krakälerei. Insbesondere natürlich im Blickfeld war dort der Datenschutz, weil das erste Mal ja so ein komplett personalisierter WM-Ticketverkauf gemacht wurde. Mit anderen Worten, man musste sich da registrieren auf der Webseite, um da überhaupt erstmal eine Chance haben, zum Ticket zu bekommen. Also gar nicht, selbst wenn man überhaupt gar kein Ticket zugesprochen bekommen hat, war man im Prinzip ja schon mit seiner eigenen Datenspur vertreten. Aber es ging ja dann auch noch weiter. Das heißt, die Leute, die so glücklich waren, dann auch ein Ticket zu erhalten, oder mehrere, haben dann eben ein hochgradig personalisiertes Ticket bekommen. Und das, außer dem Besondere daran, war wiederum, dass diese Information jetzt nicht nur auf diesem Ticket drauf gedruckt war. Tatsächlich war sie gar nicht drauf gedruckt, nur in Ausnahmen, wie wir gleich noch sehen werden. Aber dafür gab es eben einen dieser ominösen Chips, der in dieses Ticket mit eingebaut war. Ein sogenannter RFID-Chip, also ein Chip, mit dem man per Funk kommunizieren kann, also kontaktlos, ohne Drähte, ohne irgendwelche sichtbaren Stecker und Kontakte. Und das ist ja dann Thema, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Man beschäftigt sich schon länger mit RFID. Und im Chaos Computer Club Berlin wurden diese Tickets dann einer ausführlichen Untersuchung unterzogen. Es gab ja auch einen Aufruf auf der Webseite vor der WM. Wonach wurde gefragt?
Also wir wollten gerne ein paar Tickets von Leuten haben, vorzugsweise mit deren Personalien, um zu sehen, ob die wirklich da drinstehen, gegebenenfalls auch anonym, wenn das gewünscht ist, um uns dann die Tickets näher anzusehen. Vorzugsweise vor und nach dem Spiel, das hat leider nicht immer ganz geklappt. Aber ich glaube, so ungefähr ein Dutzend Tickets haben wir tatsächlich zusammengekriegt.
Na ja, das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge eigentlich. Und was habt ihr dann mit den Tickets gemacht? Also erst mal habt ihr sie euch angeguckt.
Na, erst mal ansehen. Man kann ja drauf gucken, was das so ist. Es war im Vorfeld auch schon bekannt, dass das Myfair-Chips von der Firma Philips sein werden.
Sag mal vorher, wie sahen denn diese Tickets aus? Weil die wenigsten, die jetzt hier zuhören, wenn ihr einzeln eine Hand gehabt habt.
Die Ticket ist ungefähr so breit wie eine DIN-A4-Seite. Allerdings deutlich weniger hoch, ich weiß nicht, ungefähr 5 cm.
Waren die nicht so? Zehn wahrscheinlich, ne?
Na, vielleicht auch zehn.
Okay, also wie so ein breiter Briefumschlag.
Wie ein breiter Briefumschlag, genau. Und steif, also steiferes Papier, keine Pappe, aber immerhin schon etwas steifer. Man sollte sie auch nicht klicken, knicken, stand groß und deutlich drauf. Auf der rechten Seite war ein Hologramm und eine Abrisskante, die offenbar aber trotzdem nicht benutzt wurde. Und auf der linken Seite war dann der Chip eingebittert.
Wie groß ist dieser Chip?
Na, der Chip ist sehr klein, aber es ist eine Antenne dringend herum, eine etwas größere, und das hat dann insgesamt etwa das Format einer Kreditkarte, so wie auch normale dann später andere RFID-Techs sind.
Also nimmt schon signifikant Raum ein und war sicherlich ein Grund auch, warum das Ding überhaupt so groß war. Und was war dann auf dem Ticket selber so zu lesen?
Na, auf dem Ticket steht natürlich drauf, für welches Spiel das Ticket gilt. Dann haben sie noch vorsichtshalber aufgedrückt, welcher Sektor und wo man dann reingehen muss. Dann stand manchmal, also bei den Tickets, die in regulären Verkauf gegangen sind, stand der Name drauf und ein Barcode war drauf, dessen genauen Inhalt wir dann nicht mehr uns ansehen konnten. Also da steht eine Nummer drunter und weiß man nicht.
Weißt du, was für ein Barcode das ist? Ist das so ein normaler IAN-Barcode gewesen?
Ein normaler Barcode halt. Da gibt es zwar verschiedene Systeme, aber das ist alles nicht so.
Weiß jetzt nicht genau welcher, egal. Aber wie wir noch sehen werden, dieser Barcode scheint sowieso nochmal ganz andere Zwecke zu haben als der RFID-Chip selber. Das heißt, das Augenmerk lag jetzt vor allem natürlich auf diesem RFID-Chip. Und der, wie du schon sagtest, ist von der Firma Philips, der sogenannte Myfair-Ultralight-Chip. Also Myfair schreibt sich Mifare, M-I-F-A-R-E-Ultralight. Also Mifare ist so eine komplette Familie von RFID-Chips und dieser Ultralight, das ist sozusagen der billigste von allen.
Das ist die billigste Version, die dann auch am billigsten herzustellen ist und speziell für solche Sachen wie Tickets gedacht ist.
Wie billig ist sowas?
Kann ich nicht sagen, ich würde sagen so zweistellige Cent-Bereiche.
Also so 10, 15 Cent im Vergleich zu den aufwendigeren, größeren RFID-Chips, die es ja auch gibt, die dann auch schon mal, was weiß ich, anderthalb Euro.
Also Mensa-Karte kostet 1,50 offensichtlich und richtige Krypto-Karten dann zurzeit ungefähr 15 Euro, vielleicht mehr.
Ja, die Dinger sind schon ganz schön verbreitet und jetzt halt das erste Mal auch so Large-Scale ausprobiert worden in so einem WM-Szenario, das war ja ein Novum. Wie weit reicht so ein RFID-Chip, also wenn man den jetzt ausliest über Funk, aus welcher Distanz kann man den auslesen?
Na, das kommt drauf an, ob man nur zuhören will oder ob man den Chip tatsächlich aktiv betreiben muss. Das Problem oder der Vorteil von so einem RFID-Chip ist nämlich, dass er keine eigene Stromversorgung hat, keine Batterie, sondern vom Lese-Schreibgerät mit Strom versorgt werden muss über das Funkfeld. Und das geht nur über ungefähr 15 cm gut. Die tatsächliche Funkkommunikation empfangen kann man weiter, 1 Meter, 4 Meter mindestens.
Also das heißt, wenn es eine Quelle gibt, die da genug Saft reingibt, dann kann man das auch aus größerer Entfernung lesen. Kann man auch mithören, während ein anderes Gerät aussieht?
Genau, dieses Szenario mithören ist vergleichsweise unproblematisch.
Wie weit würde das dann gehen?
Na, das war der Meter, vier Meter, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, kommt drauf an. Also es ist halt Funk, wer die größere Antenne hat, gewinnt.
Und okay, habt ihr Informationen darüber, wie jetzt die Situation in den Stadien konkret war? Also man kam da irgendwie an, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, gab es zwei Sicherheitszonen im Wesentlichen. Das heißt, erst mal so eine einfache Sicherheitszone außen, wo man durchkam. Da wurde aber dieser Chip, glaube ich, noch nicht ausgelesen, oder?
Also ich war ja selbst nicht in dem Stadion, aber ich habe Berichte und anderes Material dazu gesehen. Und da steht dann, es gibt eine äußere Sicherheitszone, wo das Ticket erst mal visuell kontrolliert wird. Also sie schauen, ob da richtige Spielnummer drauf steht, ob du den richtigen Eingang gefunden hast. Vielleicht gucken sie sich auch mal an, ob das so ungefähr das richtige Format hat. Und dann kommst du da erst mal rein. Da gibt es dann sicherlich Geschäft oder was weiß ich, was zu futtern kaufen. Currywurst und Gutweiser. Und dann tatsächlich reinzukommen, muss man dann in die innere Sicherheitszone. Da gibt es dann Schleusen davor, so wie man das halt so kennt, mit einem RFID-Leser. Die Schleuse lässt dich dann nur rein, wenn der RFID-Leser dich durchlässt.
Also so eine Schranke, so ein Teil, was dann halt aufgeht.
Genau.
Das heißt, man muss das Ticket dann schon direkt lesen lassen.
Genau, also das kommt drauf an. Es gab dann offensichtlich nach den Berichten, die wir gehört haben, verschiedene Typen von Lesegeräten. Einige, wo man das Ticket auf der einen Seite reinsteckt, dann rutscht das da irgendwie so durch und kommt woanders wieder raus.
So wie in der Londoner U-Bahn.
Genau, und man kann dann durchgehen. Und andere, wo vor der Schranke so eine Art Mulde ist, wo man das Ticket reinhalten muss. Was dann, also das Ticket ist ja, wie gesagt, relativ lang und der Chip relativ kurz. Und offensichtlich hat eine beträchtliche Anzahl der Personen es falsch rum reingehalten. Hintenweis, das bunte ist der Chip, nicht das Vologramm. Sodass sie dann neben so einer Schranke immer noch eine Person postiert haben, die dann diesen ganzen Leuten das Ticket schnell aus der Hand genommen hat, umgedreht, richtig rum hingehalten, wieder zurückgegeben hat.
So wie das Assistenzpersonal an den Fahrkartenautomaten von der Bahn, der auch erstmal den Leuten erklären muss, wie das funktioniert. Okay, gut. Und dann wurde halt das Teil gelesen. Und dann wurden die Daten gelesen auf diesem Chip. Und daraufhin wurde halt entschieden, ob das jetzt ein gültiges Ticket war oder nicht. Das heißt, der Chip war im Prinzip auch maßgeblich. Er wurde nicht in Ausnahmefällen geprüft, wenn Zweifel bestanden, sondern das war eigentlich das eigentliche System, wo auch die Automatisierung quasi in den Stadien erreicht werden sollte.
Die Karten haben sich die Leute wohl nicht so genau angesehen. Also es gab da ja einige Personen, die mit nicht vollständig perfekt nachgemachten oder veränderten Karten reingegangen sind. Und das scheint wohl kein Problem gewesen zu sein, solange der Chip stimmt.
Okay, und jetzt war in diesen Sicherheitsdokumenten davon die Rede, dass es einen Online- und einen Offline-Modus gibt für diese Eingangssituation.
Ja, also das Hauptmaßgebliche bei diesem Ticketsystem ist, dass es da eine zentrale Datenbank gibt, so ein Backendsystem, wo die Daten von allen Personen, die ein Ticket haben und allen Tickets drin stehen. Und dann diese Schranken, die zur Zugangskontrolle dienen, damit verbunden sind. Um dann nachzuschlagen, ob das ein gültiges Ticket ist, ob das schon mal benutzt wurde, ob es vielleicht zurückgerufen wurde, weil der Besitzer es verloren hat. Da stehen dann auch die persönlichen Daten drin. Und es soll wohl möglich gewesen sein, dass die Schranken notfalls auch ohne Verbindung zum zentralen System arbeiten, dann im Offline-Betrieb, wo sie dann nun etwas eingeschränktere Funktionsweise haben.
Das heißt, es gibt da so eine ganze Batterie von Fehlersituationen, die es gab. Und es gab ein Verhalten im Falle von Online-Modus und ein Verhalten im Falle von Offline-Modus.
Genau, also es gibt da zwei Displays, eins, was dem Benutzer zugerichtet ist, und eins, was dem Ordner, dem Ordner-Display zugerichtet ist. Und dann gibt es noch eine Lampe, die Rot oder Grün anzeigt. Und auf dem Ordner-Display erscheinen dann ausführlichere Informationen als auf dem Benutzerdisplay. Also auf dem Ordner-Display steht dann zum Beispiel die Personalausweisnummer oder Passwortnummer oder was auch immer drin, für zur stichprobenartigen Kontrolle. Oder halt, wenn das Ticket ungültig ist, der Grund, aus dem es zurückgewiesen wurde. Ungültiges Ticket, nein, Ticket auf der Blackliste und so weiter. Ticket verloren, keine Ahnung, war schon mal drin. Das allerdings nur im Online-Modus, wenn es tatsächlich die volle Information gibt. Ansonsten steht da einfach nur ungültiges Ticket und da muss man mal schauen, was los ist.
Okay, das heißt, in dieser Datenbank steht quasi die volle Information über die Personen drin. Ausweisnummer, das heißt im Zweifel hätte man sagen können, wir sind jetzt nicht sicher, dass du wirklich du bist. Und das wurde ja wohl strichprobenartig auch getan.
Ja, also anfangs hatten sie ja noch große Töne gespuckt, dass sie jeden kontrollieren wollen. Dann hat sich das irgendwie auf stichprobenartig 1% runter geregelt und anschließend war das wohl am Ende gar keiner oder so ähnlich.
Da fragt man sich natürlich, ob sie das wirklich von Anfang an vorgehabt haben oder ob das nur so Scare-Tactics waren, dass sie so nach dem Motto kommt gar nicht erst auf die Idee, die Dinge auf dem Schwarzmarkt zu verkaufen, wir kriegen euch sowieso wahrscheinlich sowas. Ausweisnummer, na gut, dann gehört ja im Prinzip auch noch ein Ausweistyp, weil ja nicht jeder die gleichen Ausweis hat.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass da auch der Typ beisteht.
Okay, das heißt, die würden dann im Zweifelsfall angezeigt bekommen, hier der hat Reisepass sowieso und wenn er den jetzt nicht dabei hat, okay. Und dieser Online-Modus hat ja dann auch vorgesehen, dass man quasi auch im Nachhinein Leuten, die eine gültige Karte haben, noch den Zugang zum Stadion aber versperren kann.
Ja, also es gibt da diese Blacklist und die berühmte Datei Gewaltheter Sport und das soll da alles irgendwie abgeglichen worden sein, so dass dann die Person, die man als Problem-Fan, heißt das ja neuerdings, identifiziert hat, nicht mehr reinlassen will.
Die Problem-Bären.
Die auch nicht, vorzugsweise.
Also quasi die Hooligan-Kartei. Mal etwas saloper formuliert.
Und das soll wohl dann da alles in der Datenbank drin gestanden haben, haben auch welche Personen im Stadion Hausverbot haben und so weiter. Und die Tickets sollten dann sofort abgewiesen werden. Mit entsprechender Anzeige im Ordner-Display, was dann zur Folge hat, dass da gleich Personen durch Polizei ergreifen lassen oder so weiter.
Der einzige Fall, der so richtig berichtet wurde, war ja glaube ich diese Trommler-Gruppe aus Mexiko, die dann irgendwie bei irgendeinem Spiel nicht reingelassen worden ist, weil sie angeblich, was war da das Argument, sie hätten den Block gewechselt im Stadion, was natürlich auch irgendwie absurd war, weil das ja gar nicht erfasst wird.
Den Block? Also es gibt da diese Sektorentrennung und man darf nur in den richtigen Sektor rein. Da steht da auch noch irgendwie, dass man da kontrollieren soll, ob das der richtige Sektor ist und wenn es nicht der richtige Sektor ist, dann wirst du auch ganz schnell wieder weggeschickt.
Na gut, das spielt jetzt auch erstmal keine große Rolle. Jetzt war natürlich eine der großen Fragen, wie dieser Personalisierungsvorgang eigentlich tatsächlich vonstattengeht. Offensichtlich ist diese RFID-Tickets müssen ja auch irgendwann mal produziert werden, aber so wenn die quasi aus der Firma, wo die produziert werden, herausfallen, dann fehlen ja wahrscheinlich diese Personalisierungsinformationen, weil die ja erst später durch den Kauf dazukommen.
Ja genau, also es ist schon ein etwas tollere Typ von RFID. Es gibt ja schon seit diversen Jahren diese einfachen Transponder-Systeme, die einfach bloß eine Nummer ausgeben, wo dann einfach bloß so und so viele Bit eindeutiger Identifier rausfallen, da muss man dann zwangsweise eine Art Plattenbank nachschlagen.
Also Transponder ist andere Bezeichnung für das, was eine RFID-Chip ist.
Transponder verwendet man eigentlich mehr für diese alten Systeme, die einfach bloß eine Nummer ausgeben. Das ist dieses Vari-Chip, was mittlerweile relativ berühmt ist, weil sich einige Leute das in den Oberarm injizieren lassen. Das ist jetzt hier diese WM-Tickets, sind aber schon das neuere Zeug, da ist tatsächlich Speicher drauf, die man beschreiben kann, wo man dann Informationen nachträglich eintragen kann nach der Produktion.
Wie viel Speicher ist da drin?
In diesem Myfair-Ultralight-Chip sind 64-Bytes Speicher, da gibt es dann auch größere Versionen, wie gesagt, wie mehr kosten.
Und die Tickets, die ihr bekommen habt, die habt ihr dann mit einem entsprechenden Lesegerät ausgelesen und die Daten einfach gesammelt und verglichen. Und dann habt ihr quasi auf Basis der Teile, die identisch sind und die nicht identisch sind, analysiert, was wohl eigentlich drauf ist.
Genau, scharf drauf gucken und eventuell AHA-Schreien.
Und ja, was haben eure AHA-Momente dann ergeben?
Na, also zuerst mal guckt man sich natürlich das Datenblatt an, um zu sehen, was da überhaupt drauf sein sollte. Und dann sieht man, dass vorne so ein Bereich ist, der nur einmal beschreibbar ist und nicht mehr beschrieben, danach nicht mehr geändert werden kann. Und dann kommt irgendwie ein Teil, der frei vom Benutzer verändert werden kann. Und dann guckt man sich den vorne an, das ist dann weniger interessant und dann weiter hinten stehen interessante Sachen. Zum Beispiel findet man im Datenblatt heraus, dass es da Lockpits gibt, mit denen man einzelne Teile des Chips sperren kann gegen Schreiben. Und wenn man sich die Lockpits auf den WM-Tickets anschaut, sieht man, dass die alle gleich sind und dass sie alle WM-Tickets in zwei Teile aufgeteilt haben. Ein Teil, der nur noch lesbar ist, nicht mehr beschrieben werden kann und ein Teil, der beschrieben und gelesen werden kann. In dem vorderen Bereich, der nur noch lesbar ist, nicht mehr beschrieben werden kann, stand dann irgendwas, was wir nicht genau zuordnen konnten. Das waren acht Byte, die relativ zufällig aussahen und wo wir dann davon ausgehen, dass das eine Datenbank-ID ist, die dann tatsächlich zu diesem Lookup in der Datenbank des WM...
Dazu muss man sagen, jeder Headchip hat sowieso, jetzt auch von der Spezifikation her, schon mal eine eigene ID.
Genau, es gibt für jeden Chip einen Unique Identifier, der auch für die Kommunikation wichtig ist.
Und der ist ja auch in diesem 64 Byte mit drin.
Genau, der ist vorne drin, der ist schon bei der Herstellung fest und wird...
Also jeder Chip kommt aus der Fabrik schon mal mit, ich bin sowieso und wie viele Bits sind das?
Es sind sieben Byte.
Sieben Byte. Okay, also da geht auf jeden Fall eine Menge rein. Das heißt, man kann auf jeden Fall jedes Ticket, unabhängig davon, was jetzt nach Kauf und Personalisierung da reingeschrieben wird, auf jeden Fall erstmal schon mal unterscheiden.
Genau. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch überprüft haben, aber das wissen wir nicht so genau.
Okay, und jetzt gab es dann diesen, gleich danach, diesen anderen Bereich, der immer irgendwie anders war und das habt ihr jetzt als Datenbank-ID quasi aufgefasst.
Genau, das sah halt zufällig aus und kann man nichts weiter mit anfangen, wird dann eine ID sein. Danach kam dann etwas, was man wieder sehr gut, das war das Erste, was wir erkennen konnten, das war die Nummer des Spiels, die Spielnummer, die stand da einfach so drin, die konnte man dann auch gut sehen.
Warum konnte man das gut sehen?
Na, weil sie BCD-kodiert war. Also wenn man sich so ein Ticket ansieht oder wenn man allgemein sich unbekannte Daten ansieht, nimmt man meistens einen Hexdampfer, weil man dann alles darstellen kann, was da möglicherweise drin ist und nicht einfach nur als ASCII interpretieren. Und BCD-kodiert heißt, dass die einzelnen Ziffern, also 0 bis 9, tatsächlich als Hexziffer 0 bis 9 abgebildet werden, sodass die 64 tatsächlich im Hexdampfer so richtig drinsteht, wenn das jetzt Spiel 64 war oder 46 war, glaube ich, das erste, was wir gesehen haben.
Und das heißt, unter anderem, also die Spielnummer steht ja auch aufgedruckt auf dem Ticket drauf und die gleiche Information ist da auch nochmal reingeschrieben. Wir befinden uns aber jetzt sozusagen immer noch in diesem Read-Only-Bereich. Das ist auch etwas, was ich nicht ändern kann. Also man kann nicht sein Ticket nehmen und eine andere Spielnummer draufschreiben. Genau, das geht so wenig. Okay. Und was gibt es dann sonst noch? Dann gab es noch so einen komischen Ländercode, glaube ich.
Ja, dann waren da ein paar, also drei Bites immer, die man dann in der ASCII-Darstellung wieder gut sehen konnte. Da stand dann bei den ersten Tickets, die wir gesehen haben, D-E-U drin, also DOI, was dann wahrscheinlich für Deutschland steht. Wir haben dann andere Tickets gesehen, da stand da GBR drin, für Großbritannien. Und einige sehr interessanterweise hatten da nur Leerzeichen. Das waren auch die einzigen, die wir gesehen haben. Wir wissen nicht so genau, was für ein Land das jetzt sein soll, ob das jetzt irgendwie der Ticketinhaber ist oder, keine Ahnung, Ausstellungsort. Aber irgendwie sowas in der Art sicherlich.
Okay, also in irgendeiner Form gibt es zumindest eine Zuordnung auf das Land. Wahrscheinlich, ja, was könnte das schon sein? Wahrscheinlich, wo ist, was weiß ich, der Landeskanal oder die Zuteilung?
Genau, das wäre die Möglichkeit, dass...
Irgendwie sowas. Und das sind jetzt diese ganzen Read-Only-Informationen.
Und dann in dem Read-Only-Bereich war noch ein bisschen Platz, aber der war dann nur mit Nullen aufgefüllt.
Ah ja, okay, also not used sozusagen. Okay, und dann kam, was für ein Bereich, so ein Read-Write-Bereich.
Dann kamen Bereiche, in die man reinschreiben konnte, ja.
Okay, und lesen kann. Und was war da wohl drin?
Na, da war eine Zahl drin, wieder BCD-kodiert offensichtlich, die wir nicht genau erkennen konnten. Aber wir hatten das Glück, dass wir zwei Tickets von der gleichen Person hatten. Und bei den beiden Tickets stand die gleiche Zahl drin, die aber unterschiedlich war von den Zahlen aller anderen Tickets. Also sind wir davon ausgegangen, dass das irgendeine Personennummer ist oder Bestellernummer, wie Starbuck vermutete, oder irgendwie sowas in der Art, die dann die Person wahrscheinlich identifiziert.
Okay, das heißt, diese eigentliche Database-ID, die wir vorher da schon vermutet haben, ist wahrscheinlich eher die Verankerung des Tickets selber. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen haben sie nicht die Ticket-ID, also nicht die RFID-ID, die da sowieso mit drin ist genommen, sondern aus irgendwelchen Gründen auch immer eine andere.
Na, das macht man gerne mal mal. Also man designt erst sein System, dann fällt da bei dem System sowieso eine Datenbank-ID raus und dann guckt man, ach, das könnte man ja auch auf so einen RFID schreiben. Da ist schon eine ID, naja, macht nichts. Schreiben wir uns noch dazu.
Okay, verstehe. Ja, sinnvolle Erklärung. So, das heißt aber, die eigentliche Personennummer ist dann eben die Zuordnung, wer hat die gekauft? Also mit anderen Worten, in diesem Ticket befindet sich tatsächlich eine Personenzuordnung, auch wenn da jetzt kein Klarname drin steht und auch sonst nichts, Geschlechtgröße, was auch immer. Keine Ahnung, was die Leute alles angegeben haben beim Kauf. Die jetzt sozusagen die Ownership hat. Das heißt, man kann im Prinzip auch sagen, wenn da jetzt zwei, ja wie kann denn überhaupt eine Person, ach so, die hat zwei gekauft, aber damit können schon zwei separate Personen rein. Oder waren das vom gleichen Spiel?
Nein, von verschiedenen Spielen. Also gleiche Personen, verschiedene Spiele, gleiche Personennummer.
Und sonst noch irgendwas an Informationen jetzt mit auf den Teil?
Na, das war erstmal das, was wir gesehen haben. Wir haben leider kein unpersonalisiertes Ticket gesehen. Also da stand schon immer das drin. Und wir haben erst sehr spät Tickets nach der Benutzung gesehen. Also wir haben dann sehr, sehr spät erst mitgekriegt, dass nach der Benutzung in dem Schreibbandteil noch mehr Daten drin waren plötzlich.
Das heißt, der Inhalt der RFID, des RFID-Speichers hat sich geändert, nachdem Leute tatsächlich im Stadion waren.
Genau.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo die das Ticket durch den Slider geschoben haben und reingegangen sind, wurde wahrscheinlich diese Information vermerkt. Also so eine Art rein-raus.
Wahrscheinlich so durch welches Ticket, durch welches Tor er zu welcher Zeit gegangen ist oder so was in der Art.
Ja, man konnte ja aber auch mit den Tickets das Stadion wieder verlassen.
Genau, und das hat man dann wahrscheinlich auch drauf gespeichert. Also wir haben Tickets gesehen, die nur einmal beim Anfang des Spiels reingegangen sind und am Ende dann halt mit allen raus. Also beim Rausgehen am Ende des Spiels wird nicht nochmal ausgebucht. Und wir haben welche gesehen, die dann extra absichtlich mehrfach rein und rausgegangen sind und da waren das tatsächlich mehr Daten als bei dem anderen.
Das heißt, da wurde was hochgezählt oder?
Na, es hat sich an zwei Stellen was geändert. Vorne gibt es noch einen Bereich, der, wenn man das Datenblatt liest, weiß man, dass der nur beschreibbar ist, aber nicht wieder zurückgesetzt werden kann. Also da sind 32 Bit, die man nur von 0 auf 1 setzen kann, aber nie wieder von 1 auf 0. Das haben sie dann reingebaut, weil das halt extra zur Verwendung als Ticket gedacht ist. Und das kennt man ja von der S-Bahn oder so, irgendwelche Streifenkarten, die dann zum Beispiel für 10 Fahrten gültig sind. Und der Plan ist dann, dass man dann für jede Fahrt ein Bit setzt und das Bit kann wieder weggemacht werden.
Also mit anderen Worten, es gab eine endliche Zahl von rein rausgeh-Vorgängen.
Tatsächlich gehen wir davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich 8 sind. Also sie haben zwei Bytes verwendet und wahrscheinlich beim Reingehen das eine Byte und beim Rausgehen das andere, so wie das aussieht.
Okay, also man darf achtmal das Stadion verlassen und wieder reingehen, das ist ja eigentlich durchaus fair. Doch nicht, dass es irgendjemand gemacht hat, aber zumindest hatten sie die Luft nach oben.
Genau, unsere Tester haben es auch nur dreimal gemacht.
Du hast vorhin diese Lock Bits erwähnt. Was machen die genau?
Na, das ist dafür da, dass die Daten anschließend nicht mehr geändert werden können. Also wenn man das Ticket kriegt, ist es vollkommen beschreibbar, bis auf den Anfangsteil, den der Hersteller festgelegt hat. Und da könnte ja ein Schelm kommen und noch selber Sachen reintun. Also werden die Tickets, nachdem sie das beschrieben haben, was draufstehen soll, gelockt. Da setzt man einfach in den Bereich, der nicht wieder zurückgesetzt werden kann, da so eine Bit, also schreibt eine 1 rein oder ein F oder was auch immer. Und dann sind die Sektoren, für die dieses Bit gilt, nicht mehr beschreibbar. Können nur noch gelesen werden.
Also man kann sich im Prinzip diesen 64-Bit-Speicher nach Gusto einteilen, in Bereiche, die ohnehin nur lesbar sind, wo man einmal was reinschreiben kann oder wo man eben beliebig rein- und rausschreiben kann. Und ich glaube, man kann aber auch sicherstellen, dass sich dieser Status nicht ändert.
Genau, es gibt dann zu den Lock-Bits noch Block-Locking-Bits, die dann Lock-Bits für die Lock-Bits sind.
Also mit anderen Worten, dieser RFID-Bereich war auch so, dass man sicherstellen konnte, dass der auch immer les- und schreibbar bleibt.
Genau, da waren die Block-Locking-Bits gesetzt, so dass man die Lock-Bits für den Bereich nicht mehr setzen konnte.
Naja, jetzt gab es ja viel Diskussion im Vorfeld darüber. Einerseits natürlich über diesen Datenschutzaspekt des Verkaufs. Wir wollen uns ja jetzt hier eigentlich erst mal auf die Tickets als solche konzentrieren. Aber es gab natürlich auch so diverse Überlegungen, inwieweit jetzt diese Technik genutzt werden kann, um was wären denn jetzt eigentlich so Szenarios, wo darüber geredet kann man die Dinger kopieren. Ja, ist es möglich, wenn man jetzt in der Lage ist, physikalisch diese Tickets zu machen, kann man die in irgendeiner Form kopieren oder kann man so ein bisschen Digital-Vandalismus betreiben und Leute daran hindern, dass sie ins Ding kommen. Weil dadurch, dass RFID ja keinen direkten Kontakt mit der Karte bzw. mit dem Chip erfordert, wäre ja im Prinzip so ein Zugang möglich. Was ist denn da ein realistisches Szenario?
Also wir haben uns überlegt, diese Antennen, mit denen man sowas auf Größe, Reichweiten als diese spezifizierten 10 cm macht, die sind rund und groß und wenn man sie selber baut, nimmt man meistens einen Hula-Hoop-Reifen als Basis und das ist ja sowieso sportlich und so kann man sicherlich gut tarnen. Und ein Szenario wäre zum Beispiel gewesen, man nimmt sich so einen Hula-Hoop-Reifen und geht damit einmal durch die U2 oder so, die zum Olympiastadion fährt. Da sind die Leute auf dichtem Raum und wenn man Glück hat, kommt man nahe genug an.
Also jetzt sozusagen unmittelbar vor dem Spiel?
Zum Beispiel unmittelbar vor dem Spiel oder einfach irgendwie zu anderen Gelegenheiten, wenn man am Flughafen oder so, wenn man mal den Verdacht hat, dass da größere Ansendungen von Fans sind.
Wenn da gerade mal wieder was gelandet ist, wo es voll mit Fans ist. Aber U-Bahn ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller vor dem Spiel.
U-Bahn ist besser, weil man ist näher dran.
Aber da hat man natürlich auch weniger Zeit, um jetzt zu reagieren, um letzten Endes da auch was zu tun, weil die fahren ja dann alle zum Stadion. Ja, aber was kann man jetzt machen? Also man kann auf jeden Fall den vollständigen Inhalt des Chips jederzeit problemlos auslesen.
Genau, da ist keinerlei Sicherheit im Spiel.
Wenn ich jetzt mit dem Hula-Hoop-Reifen um den Bauch da einmal durchmarschiere, dann könnte man sagen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sich von 100 Tickets, die da jetzt sich vielleicht drin befinden, 10 oder 20, ausgelesen bekommen, ist relativ hoch.
Ja, also man hat immer noch das Problem, dass man da auf die Reichweite kommen muss. Wie gesagt, 15 cm sind zurzeit realistisch. Das ist leider noch ein Problem. Man müsste mal schauen, ob man das erweitern kann. Aber in dem Bereich ist es sicherlich vollkommen problemlos möglich, das auszulesen.
Okay, aber nun sind ja diese Dinger relativ eng bepackt, die U-Bahn. Also wenn man sich da auch einmal durchdringelt mit seinem Hula-Hoop-Reifen, dann sieht das schon ganz anders aus. Okay, ob das nun ein realistisches Szenario ist, sei mal dahingestellt, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall denkbar. Was hätte man dann? Dann hätten wir im Prinzip alle Informationen. Könnten wir die jetzt genauso auf ein anderes RFID-Ticket draufschreiben, wenn wir so ein Roling hätten?
Genau, also da ist noch das Problem mit der unbeschreibbaren Nummer am Anfang, die der Hersteller festgelegt hat. Die wird offensichtlich geprüft, wir haben das ausprobiert. Da müsste man sich dann überlegen, es ist wie gesagt keinerlei Crypto im Spiel, das heißt, man kann, wenn man so eine etwas intelligentere Karte hat, nicht so eine Myfair-Ultralight-Karte, sondern zum Beispiel eine mit einem Prozessor drauf, wo man die UID setzen kann zum Beispiel, das wahrscheinlich problemlos kopieren.
Also die UID ist diese Hersteller-ID?
Genau, die der Hersteller festgelegt hat und die nicht mehr verändert werden kann, zumindest bei diesem Typ von Tickets.
Okay, aber das kommt jetzt bei denen ja nicht in Frage. Achso, du meinst, wenn man jetzt sich einen teureren Chip nimmt, der sich aber elektrisch genauso verhält?
Genau, es ist Funk und es ist digital und es ist sicherlich problemlos möglich, sich genauso zu verhalten wie ein richtiges Ticket.
Also man könnte im Prinzip einen vollständigen Klon herstellen, aber dann hätte man schon mal einen höheren Kostenaufwand hat man sowieso bei der ganzen Sache. Das ist ja nochmal eine andere Frage, ob sich das alles lohnt. Und dann? Das heißt im Prinzip, wenn ich fix dabei bin und irgendwie schneller zum Stadion komme, könnte ich anstatt der Person eigentlich reingehen?
Genau, man hat dann noch das leichte Problem, dass man keine neuen Tickets erstellen kann, sondern nur vorhandene Tickets kopieren, sodass dann nur eines dieser beiden Tickets reinkommt. Wer zuerst da ist, hat dann gewonnen.
Weil dieses Bit dann wahrscheinlich auch in der Datenbank gesetzt wird? Genau, weil man die Datenbank noch im Rücken hat. Ist das sicher, dass sie diese Informationen auch wirklich speichern? Ich meine, sie speichern es ja auf dem Ticket.
Ich würde es tun. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie es tun.
Also wäre eigentlich schön doof, wenn sie diese Informationen nicht sammeln würden. Weil letzten Endes haben sie natürlich auch ein großes Interesse daran, überhaupt zu wissen, wer war denn da. Also kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen. Ja, aber so eine besonders große Bedrohung erscheint mir das ja nicht zu sein.
Na, kommt drauf an. Also aus dem Sicherheitsaspekt ist es natürlich eine Bedrohung. So absolut gesehen. Jetzt relativ mag das vielleicht kein großer Anteil sein, aber es ist schon mal da.
Was meinst du jetzt genau mit Sicherheitsaspekt? Sicherheit von wem oder was?
Na, also wenn ich ein Sicherheitssystem bauen würde, würde ich das vorzugsweise so machen, dass sowas zum Beispiel nicht geht.
Dass man es zumindest schon mal nicht auslesen kann oder dass man es nicht kopieren kann?
Ja, das ist beides. Also das hängt eng miteinander zusammen. Es gibt ja andere Systeme, wo man ohne den richtigen Schlüssel gar nicht erst lesen kann und die kann man dementsprechend auch nicht kopieren ohne den Schlüssel.
Das sind dann aber teurere Chips. Und die gibt es aber.
Gibt es auch, ja.
Und das würde dann wie funktionieren? Also dann hätte das System quasi einen geheimen Schlüssel und würde mit dem Chip in dem Ticket erst mal unter Verwendung dieses geheimen Schlüssels eine sichere Kommunikation aufbauen, die sich jetzt so ohne Weiteres, wenn man diesen Schlüssel nicht hat, nicht nachvollziehen lässt, nicht kopieren lässt. Was kosten solche kryptofigen Teile?
Das ist dann das nächste. Also MyFair Classic zum Beispiel kann das. Das sind ungefähr, also bei uns in der Mensa verkaufen sie für 1,50. Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ach, das ist der Chip, den du vorhin schon erwähnt hast. Der hat also im Wesentlichen mehr, was ist da anders konkret?
Der hat mehr Speicher, der ist extra für solche Anwendungen als elektronische Geldbörse gedacht. Also man kann da was drauf definieren, dass es einen Geldwert speichert, den man nur erhöhen oder erniedrigen kann. Wobei man zum Erhöhnen und Erniedrigen verschiedene Schlüssel festlegen kann. Und der hat dann tatsächlich Krypto, das ist zwar proprietäre Philips-Krypto, von der keiner weiß, wie gut sie ist und sie hat nur 48 Bit, aber sie ist immerhin da.
Genau, muss erstmal geknackt werden. Gibt es denn da keine Standards in dem RFID-Bereich?
Standards gibt es schon, aber das MyFair-System ist schon relativ alt und das proprietäres Philips-System.
Welche Verbreitung haben diese MyFair-Systems?
Offensichtlich die größte. Also in der Wikipedia steht auch immer bloß das größte System und die Londoner Nahverkehr machen das zum Beispiel, da heißt das dann Oystercard. Und auch allgemein ist Philips, dieses MyFair-System, wohl das verbreitetste. Deswegen wundert es mich ehrlich gesagt, dass es noch nicht geknackt ist, aber...
Okay, das ist ja schon mal eigentlich ein ganz interessantes Ergebnis. Gab es auch Überlegungen, das jetzt mal konkret auszuprobieren, anstatt eines Original-Tickets in irgendeiner Form da aufzutrauen?
Ja, also man hat es tatsächlich probiert, einmal mit einem anderen MyFair-Ultralight-Chip, wo dann am Ende die Daten, die in einem normalen Ticket drin standen, reinkopiert wurden. Aber den Anfang konnten wir halt nicht ändern. Und das hat das System dann auch prompt zurückgewiesen, wie es sich gehört.
Okay, aber wir wissen nicht, wer das gemacht hat.
Genau.
Wenn man jetzt, jetzt habt ihr ja hier so einiges zum Einsatz gebracht. Ich denke, wer das jetzt so gehört hat, mag ja vielleicht mal selber auf die Idee kommen, bestehende Tickets-Systeme oder eben auch solche Mensa-Karten oder so, mal selber ein bisschen unter die Lupe zu nehmen. Was für Technik war denn jetzt nötig, um diese Analyse durchzuführen?
Na wir haben einen Standard RFID-Räder benutzt. Das war ein, oh Gott, Cartman 5121.
Standard im Sinne von dieses ISO-Standards, den auch dieser MyFair-System im Moment hat.
Genau, also es gibt da ein halbes Dutzend, vielleicht nicht ganz Standards dazu. Dieses MyFair-System basiert auf ISO-14443 oder soweit ich das gehört habe war dann ISO-14443 einfach nur MyFair. Dieses ISO-14443 ist für Proximity-Coupling gedacht, bis 10-15 Zentimeter, nein, Vincinity-Coupling. Also Nahbereich, während... Während ist da, da gibt es ja noch andere Standards, zum Beispiel 15-693, wenn ich das jetzt richtig in Erinnerung habe, das ist dann Proximity-Coupling, also etwas breiterer Nahbereich, ungefähr einen Meter. Und die arbeiten alle auf 13,56 Megahertz. Und da gibt es dann Rieder zu kaufen, die dann einen Chip von Philips enthalten, in dem Fall, der im Wesentlichen das meiste, was 13,56 Megahertz benutzt, sprechen kann, also in diesem Fall ISO 14443. Da gibt es dann auch Untertypen A und B und es war jetzt A, aber das ist nicht so weiter wichtig.
Und was kostet so ein Rieder?
Ja, die sind momentan noch relativ teuer, also 90 Euro war dieses Modell, weil das auch einen kontaktbasierten, normalen Smartcard-Rieder enthält. Der Philips-Ship, den sie dann darauf gesetzt haben, um RFID zu machen, kostet wohl, soweit ich das gehört habe, um so 9 Euro. Und LaForge arbeitet in der Tat gerade daran, so was mal als Bauplan zum Selberbauen zur Verfügung zu stellen, weil sie diese Integration mit dem Philips-Ship in der Tat nicht so besonders toll gemacht haben. Also das Proben bei Design möchte man fast meinen. Na, der Philips-Ship hat zum Beispiel ein Interruptin, den sie nicht verbunden haben, das heißt, man muss das Ding ständig pollen. Der Chip hat 64-Bit-Fifo, man möchte aber gegebenenfalls bis zu 256-Bit senden.
Also FIFO First-In, First-Out.
Genau, also so ein Zwischenbuffer. Und man möchte 256-Bit senden und mit 460 Kilobit pro Sekunde, da hat man nicht viel Zeit, den FIFO nachzufüllen. Wenn man dann den Chip noch dauernd pollen muss, ob der FIFO denn jetzt schon leer ist, dann geht das nicht.
Kann schnell mal was schief gehen.
Also es geht immer schief.
Wie wird dieses Lesegerät angeschlossen?
Das ist über USB, ganz normal. Also fast ganz normal.
Gut, aber es ist ja in dem Sinne kein Standardgerät. Das heißt, man braucht auch dafür noch die passende Software, um damit zu konfrontieren.
Genau, also das verhält sich erst mal wie ein normaler Smartcard-Rider für kontaktbasierte Karten. Und mit dem RFID-Teil spricht man dann über Escape-Commandos. Und da stellt der Hersteller OmniKey einen Treiber bereit, zum Beispiel für Linux und Windows und so weiter. So, dass das dann wie ein zusätzlicher Smartcard-Rider oder ein Slot aussieht. Man benutzt dann PCSC. Na, PCSC ist dieses Mittelwehr-Dings, was man benutzt, um auf Smartcard-Rider zuzugreifen.
Und dann darauf spezifisch nochmal die Komplikation.
Und da haben sie da einen Treiber drauf, und der spricht dann mit richtigen Prozessorkarten RFIDs, wie mit einer normalen kontaktbasierten Prozessorkarte. Da sieht man den Unterschied gar nicht. Und für diese Myfair-Karten, das sind ja dann nur Speicherkarten, müsste man dann noch extra Software vom Hersteller benutzen. Das ist aber alles gar nicht so schlimm, weil LaForge da auch selber was gehackt hat, das nennt sich dann LipRFID. Kann bis jetzt im Wesentlichen mit diesem Reader reden. Also es ist da abstrakter angelegt, aber es gibt auch noch nicht so viele andere.
Also LipRFID ist eine Softwarebibliothek, die dann vermutlich mal unter Unix-Linux läuft und zum Einsatz gebracht werden kann. Das heißt, wenn man so ein Reader hat und diese Library nimmt, dann hat man schon relativ abstraktes Interface, um damit zu arbeiten.
Genau, da sind auch ein paar Tools bei. Die anderen muss man sich dann selber schreiben, wenn man sie braucht. Also es ist dann halt eine Bibliothek, die dann die entsprechende Funktionsverhöhung zur Verfügung stellt, um dann mit diesen Karten zu arbeiten.
Ja, da sollte man vielleicht auch gleich nochmal dazu erwähnen, dass es zu dieser LipRFID auch einen Vortrag gab von Laforge und dem Kollegen Milosz auf dem 22C3. Den Link dazu findet ihr natürlich hier in den Show-Notes zu der Sendung oder halt auch direkt einfach auf dem Archiv-Server, also direkt zur RFID, eine Stunde Vortrag, direkt vom Kongress als Audio und Video. Wer mag, kann da halt auch nochmal mit reinschauen. Was gibt es sonst noch so für Ressourcen, die jetzt in dem Zusammenhang wichtig sind? Also, in der Wikipedia steht natürlich so einiges drin, aber es gibt auch jetzt konkret zu diesem Projekt ein Berliner Wiki.
Genau, also in dem Wiki des Berliner Chaos Computer Clubs haben wir einiges zusammengetragen. Da sind dann auch Link zu weiteren Informationen. Ich habe, glaube ich, gar nicht so viele weitere Informationen benutzt aus den Standards, aber da steht noch einiges verlinkt.
Genau, also httpsberlinccc.de ist unser öffentliches Wiki hier im Berliner CCC. Und da gibt es allerlei Informationen auf der Seite RFID, unter anderem auch einen Link zu dieser konkreten Projektgeschichte RFID-Tickets zur Fußball-WM. Und da steht dann auch das ganze Format, das wir gerade besprochen haben, noch mal im Detail drin. Und wer Lust hat, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, kann das ja dort tun. Ja, was ist so dein eigener Antrieb, dich jetzt so mit RFID zu beschäftigen? Ist das jetzt nur die Angst vor der bösen Überwachung? RFID ist ja immer in der öffentlichen Diskussion da stark negativ belegt, oder hast du da auch Fun-Projekte am Start?
Nö, einfach bloß so zum Rumspielen, weil es da ist, mehr oder weniger. Ich beschäftige mich auch sonst mehr mit Smartcards, also den richtigen smarten Smartcards. Und die kann man ja auch über RFID ansprechen, das macht dann der Rieder auch sehr schön.
Ah ja, also die Chips, die jetzt sowieso in allen...
In den Pässen drin sind, ja.
In den Pässen drin sind zum Beispiel, genau, oder halt auch in Geldkarten und so weiter.
Das ist dann die etwas teurere Variante, die dann Krypto kann und alles möglich, alle andere.
Ja, super, würde ich sagen. Dann haben wir das mal ganz gut zusammengefasst. Ich hoffe, das war wieder mal ein interessantes Thema. Und ich hoffe auch, dass jetzt die Chaosradio Express-Pause, dass das jetzt hier schon mal die Pause, die das Ende der Pause einleitet. Es gibt noch mehr Themen, die ich in der nächsten Zeit behandeln möchte. Das Thema für die nächste Chaosradio-Sendung steht allerdings auch schon fest. Also Ende dieses Monats geht es um die Gesundheitskarte. Auch da wieder viel mit Smartcard und ähnlichen Technologien am Start. Und die Sendung wird dann aber auch ein bisschen breiter diskutieren, wie also generell die Frage der Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens, weil das ist ja das, was da eigentlich dahintersteckt. Da geht es nicht nur um einzelne Karten und Geräte, sondern eben um sowas. Und ja, in der übernächsten Sendung wissen wir wahrscheinlich auch schon, was los ist. Da geht es um den Wahlcomputer. Also es steht noch so einiges an. Und ich sage jetzt erstmal Tschüss. Und ja, bis zum nächsten Mal bei Chaosradio Express, bis bald.